TPS are making the excuse of my mama was
training a thing of the past looking to
learn a bit more about how they work
well you've come to the right place
with over 500 sessions that next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
programming and all supercomputers a
deep dive on cloud TP use and stay tuned
because here's the rewind this session
was a real treat a chance to hear about
tensor processing units or TP use
directly from a member of the Google
brain team the session was broken up
into three main parts the life of a TPU
program which talks about what happens
under the hood when TPU programs are run
writing a TPU program which talks about
the API for writing TPU code and finally
feeding a TPU program which is
discussing how to get your data into the
GPU fast enough to really utilize its
powerful number-crunching abilities GPUs
were made to combat the exponentially
rising amount of compute required to
Train state of the art machine learning
models in recent years and is iterating
pretty quick TPU v3 has already come out
barely a year after version 2 TPU chips
have a powerful matrix multiplier at
their core and in the TPU version 2
which is available today as cloud GPUs
there are four TPU chips on a single
board now these boards are then arranged
into pods of 64 TPU boards each today
you can get access to a TPU with just a
couple of g-cloud commands and actually
writing code from the TPU involves using
some wrappers around the tensor flow
estimator API called TPU estimators
these wrappers help convert your
existing sensor flow program into
something that can be run on the TPU
utilizing the TF to excel a bridge there
are some limitations of course such as
requiring static shapes for your erased
and only being able to use a subset of
the operations that tensorflow can
express but in exchange you get terrific
speed how fast it's fast enough that if
you hook it up to an SSD hard drive the
hard drive won't be able to supply the
data fast enough so
instead we turn to high-performance
distributed systems one option is Google
Cloud storage you want to use regional
buckets with your data convert it to TF
record format and the files split into
one to two hundred megabyte chunks
another option is to use BigTable which
has great performance straight out of
the box up to 10x that of cloud storage
sometimes TP use they're pretty amazing
they're like time machines in ways right
instead of waiting for days or weeks
even you can iterate in hours or faster
this supercharges ml research as well as
ml product development and as we
continue to bring you these improvements
in compute power storage capability and
networking the sky is the limit so
develop your applications ethically
conduct your research responsibly and I
am super excited to see what you build
with TP use thanks for watching this
cloud rewind if you like this video give
it a thumbs up and I've included the
link to the full talk in the description
below and don't forget to subscribe for
more great content and I'll see you on
the next rewind
[Music]
you